[Music]
all right what's the story about
gentlemen
dead ass
she's the owner of an airbnb what that's
that's very important
uh she manages the airbnb oh you mean
her butt oh you guys are perverts man
that's a bbl how could you [ __ ] see
the thing that takes up 60 of them
that's the only thing you look at like
come on man
women are more than i feel like this is
going to be a cat what else were you
looking at what what else was in it what
else was it what
describe the home there's wood floors a
white fireplace there's a door yeah it's
black it is [ __ ] well well i know no
i mean there's a hallway i saw a hallway
kind of cartoonish this is kind of
constitutional anyways chess spectrum
what do you have against real estate
agents this woman
who wants the world's biggest bum says
she struggles to date she has the
world's biggest bump who wants the
world's biggest fun well tell her stop
being so picky how is she why is it so
hard for her to date because she can't
get through the door when she gets
invited to go on dates when she sits
down it's a [ __ ] mess probably would
you date a girl like that if she was
[ __ ] awesome
personality wise if she was awesome
would i date her but she just had the
world's biggest ass but i feel like
that's an artificial see wanting the
biggest ass in the world is is kind of
wow i feel like that's i think
i think it wouldn't have to do with her
i think it would have to do with my
insecurities like
i would never be able to ram her from
the back and make it to the vagina oh
yeah i was thinking about that from the
beginning
i have that problem too man me and
anthony are the same
on account
it actually makes it easier to access
when they bend over so you don't have to
stand [ __ ] but if they're that big
though
world's biggest that's true like i could
be pretty confident from time to time
but when you talk about world records
you could spread it is this enhanced
yeah but you've been digging
is this an enhanced butt okay so a woman
who has spent trying to get the bet 150
000
in her quest to have the world's biggest
bomb
says she struggles to find love due to
her extreme look i was gonna say her
crippling debt i would feel like she's
she's having a harder time finding a
[ __ ] toilet seat big enough
[Laughter]
i mean the [ __ ] is still the same so
i need to see your reference now yeah
but like don't you need like six feet of
room on each side of the toilet no
toilet's placed that way in a bathroom
it's always in a corner because she
looks proportionate i don't know how she
is a public restroom see i don't i don't
think she looks that big
i feel like there's there's women that
have her be bro you do that much bbl you
don't think you're gonna have some
health complications down the line why
there's there's no free lunches bro you
can't you can't you can't do this type
of thing it's brazilian jiu jitsu lift
blue
you know dude like you can't try to
break records like that
and then expect to like get away
scot-free yeah yeah i can't think of one
thing on a human body that if you wanted
the biggest of that that it wouldn't
complicate your dating life yeah true
say if i wanted the biggest ears yeah
would you guys be like nick why do you
need to do this
what is your what is your goal you will
have trouble with love
why it's like those farmers that just
want a trophy
pumpkin or like they want to grow really
big right so she just wants a trophy
[Laughter]
isn't attached to my body if it was like
why would you want the biggest ears and
then you're like because i could hear
everything from a mile away if i wanted
to i'd be like wait a minute that's
different you could be like the sonic
ear from the sky mold i kind of already
am but anyway uh when it comes to the
ass right mom
like when it comes to her ass like what
benefit does she have you know what it
is once it gets past a certain size what
other benefits does you have for having
this giant ad body dysmorphia exactly
and that's the question
that's that's
i think anything that is like world's
greatest biggest whatever like where
you're the standout number one i also
feel like that's a different drive
it's bragging rights yeah and then
you're in the guinness world of records
right she wants to break a record and
break some chairs but um [ __ ] faces
too right you know this is a perfect
example there's a perfect example of
someone
who pursues what they're already good at
this is clearly a passion hero story
talent and hard work someone said you
know you're going places you got a big
ass girl she goes really well maybe i
could make it bigger you know she was i
like to eat
i like eating a lot of hamburgers this
is not the way but yes and then she's
like so let me just
push my talents where i'm already like
good at i mean she's already gonna get
beat by some third world like genetic
mutation you know like you always see
that like someone with booty titus or
something yeah it's like elephantitis
probably titus is coming back she's just
gonna go no
not booty titus
i wish i had booty time i wonder if
that'll count though because it's like a
genetic like you know like the world's
biggest dick or something
i'm down to be on like the judging panel
for this so natasha crown originally
from serbia was just 20 when she had her
first ever
brazilian jiu jitsu butt lift
it has since had four more boosting her
bum to unbelievable proportions natasha
believes that when it comes to her booty
the bigger the better what's the
dimensions they have dimensions
just out of curiosity eight by eight
yeah for measurements well as far as
like how how tall is she and then how
wide is her butt like because just out
of curiosity proportions is important
yeah because it might be like this table
right exactly and as far as like her
function because i like the logistics of
this type of [ __ ] i want to know like
it just says she wants a 90 inch
backside is serbia the kind of country
where that would be like big booty girls
i mean like you know like certain
countries you just they would just like
destroy you for having a big ass is this
one like in asia they don't want a big
big butt right but then in brazil they
want a big big butt well i think she's
from serbia but i believe she lives in
the uk oh oh that's fine
where big butts cannot lie um so
no they do lie because this is like fake
right
tech modifiers so for those who don't
know uh brazilian butt lift involves a
surgeon removing fat from one part of
the body and pumping and sculpting it
into the bum wow so she constantly get
fat and then relocated which is why she
actually in order to do that she
actually eats 20 to 25 kilograms of
extra fat every day holy [ __ ]
in order to gain the necessary 20 to 25
kilograms of extra fat
she is uh
she eats everything she eats foods with
lots of carbs pizza pasta hamburgers
nutella etc i like that as a training
regimen dude
nutella pizza
i gotta do it she's training for her the
blood olympics absolutely did she should
play the [ __ ] rocky song while she's
eating that [ __ ] she's on a dangerous
mission right now bro you keep
relocating fat like that that's not good
no that's not good
four bbl's that's five now five down it
was like enough layers like if you shoot
her in the ass like it just she may not
make it to 30 bro
what is the process do they use any like
is it like boob implants or do they use
the fat of the body
yeah from your other parts of your body
when it's done right though oh i'm just
like whoo
wow
i don't know what a like a natural
brazilian butt lift looks like though
because every time i give them the girls
i'll show you guys some of them look
pretty good every time i see one it's
always like oh look at this freak that
like you know overdid it that's like the
janky ones they went to a vet like
there's ones where i was like
i was like wow
look at this specimen that's that's
different but i haven't seen a good one
i guess i'll show you but i got a
collection bbl is like the better
version of what people were doing
because i think sometimes they were
doing like synthol they were injecting
like oil oh yeah in the butt pop iron
but now i think the bbl like because
some of them when they do it right they
actually look proportionate that's what
i'm looking for yeah but it's like
hourglass that's what i'm looking for
but it still looks odd like it still
looks like oh you're a genetic freak but
it's probably is it size and shape that
deter you or is it like the actual
compound of what makes the butt because
there's something psychologically to me
where it's like if it's like their own
fat rescued in that area like at the end
of the day it's still like
that fat ass
versus if it's like some other obscure
uh like silicone or some [ __ ] you know
what i mean that's like thrown in there
and it's like truly
fake i like it when they just squat keep
it simple yeah yeah but then the ones
that are done well
it's also like it's it's a soft look
because it's not a hard ass but then
it's it's kind of confusing because
they'll have a uh they'll have a abs so
they'll be like how'd you get
a [ __ ] banging ass butt that soft
that's supposed to be on a chubby girl
but then from their shredded it's
shredded and i'm like that's weird
because they take pride or they have
like mismatched hamstrings
or like they got a diaper but like it
doesn't like keep kardashian like she
got diaper bugs
it just looks like she wearing a diaper
but also i think there's
sculpting in photoshop oh it looks kind
of good because i think they use
sculpting in photoshop so they'll get
the butt lift right and then they just
do a few adjustments to clean it up body
tune cause when i see some pictures of
kim kardashian i'm like
she her legs look really skinny
compared to her her like how big her
butt is the cheva brazilian
black lift she
yeah she got i don't know what it is
because they were doing that [ __ ] before
it was like cool
you know so i don't know if it's i'm
sure she got the best technology now you
know yeah but in general like
aesthetically
it's not it's not what i'm not into it
at all me neither i'm not a fan not a
fan it looks better without clothes i
promise you guys on some people i
promise you guys like you're standing by
that i'm sure there's some well done
bbl's but there's other ones where
you're just like oh god you censor that
one yeah that's fake like this girl
right here her actually her butt in
proportion probably looks better than
kardashians that's what i'm saying she's
proportionate looking yeah yeah i don't
think he's a really weird looking one
yeah these are really weird i just
googled kim kardashian's button honestly
i don't think any of this no they all
look normal i don't even know if they're
all looking for the weird one though
okay this is kind of kind of that was
like looks like like you [ __ ] like
took a [ __ ] air pump and let me see
let me see this is for science
he had money for the top procedures
they're gonna make it look like it never
happened bro the one on the left yeah
looks like you got two [ __ ] balloons
that's crazy the one on the left that's
nuts
it's because they don't work out their
thighs i also don't like the cottage
cheese look who has a butt like there's
like craters or it looks like there's
moons on there
like moon texture like this right here
yeah i feel like she didn't even need to
get a bbl or anything she probably
actually got a big girls don't need to
get it that's not me like you guys are
fine you guys need to be like giant
asses bro love yourselves god but maybe
maybe there's a whole section of guys
out there that like it even bigger and
then they see a normal button they're
like that's too small yeah that's true
you know [ __ ] weirdos yeah but
everyone's got their yums you know yeah
as steve says don't yuck their yums i
will if that person gets a heart attack
because they've got that [ __ ] fat bro
that's that's rough dude that's really
real no we all just love women for what
they are naturally or
unnaturally sad because a lot of that's
still competitive between women
and not so much like you know do you
think guys care as much i think
i like big booties i think like every
like just like guys girls are the same
way where like you'll do [ __ ] because of
other girls guys will do [ __ ] because of
other guys because then she kind of
waits
i definitely don't deadlift because i'm
like oh this girl's gonna check it out
and i'm like oh what bro check this out
but guys in their head they think oh if
i lift a gang away so i get buff like oh
yeah girls are gonna be into it but in
reality it's not really yeah bro you're
slow
like how do you get your triceps like
this man you got a sister
never bought a car
it's like a sports car you get all the
attention from men yeah you do all the
things wrong
or you take your fat and then you make
your penis bigger see if i can do that
i need to do that i need to do that
that's a fat [ __ ] bro
[Music]
you